i want to be clear we are not saying
throw caution in the wind and just go
forward and violate all no that's not
what anybody here is saying
and i do think that there is uh a
healthy debate
or there should be a healthy debate
among christians as to where that line
is
where disobedience to or rebellion
against a law is sinful okay but
what is completely irrefutable is to
assume that any disobedience of the law
is sinful that is incorrect
so this is the question of the day and i
think it's important uh i'll get into
the context of it
what do you especially with covid19 with
chronovirus wuflu chinese virus whatever
i call it chinese virus you call
whatever you want um truth
where do you think the line is drawn
between
respecting the law of man and the law of
god as
christians out there i've gotten a lot
of letters to this effect what do we do
when there are these laws that are
either unconstitutional or abuse of of
our
civil rights of our human rights um but
it's the law of the land because that's
something that a lot of christians
believe of course that all power is sort
of
uh is given by god because god obviously
you know he knows a lot he had it all
he's around all the time and let me tell
you where this um comes from actually
in michigan i was in michigan and i've
talked about this recently and there's a
real culture of fear there as opposed to
here
and uh a pastor of a church uh where i
got married actually they could very
easily
practice a social distancing guideline
it's a small church
and they could still carry on services
but it's
not allowed it's illegal and even then
they're not supposed to be having small
group meetings where he has it with five
guys in houses
uh and that's effectively illegal but
they've all decided that they're willing
to do it anyway
and i was sitting there going that's
almost you know drawing half the
christian fish
at that point and yeah where where do
you line up on that it's the law of the
land if you're in michigan and you have
um you know fascist
fascist wicked wench of the west whitmer
telling you that you can't have a small
group in a house as a christian
is it your job to say well i have to
submit to the authority of the
government or
is that at a certain point um
undercutting god's law and i think it's
something that a lot of christians get
wrong i hate to use this word nuanced
there are some situations here and i
think we'll get into it that are nuanced
but there are
some uh concepts that are irrefutable
that i think a lot of christians
miss so uh before we get to it where do
you guys uh line up here
well so and i think it's a really good
question because there are a lot of
churches across the nation that are in
states that are
locking it down or giving them some
openness to say hey you can do this but
congregation members are saying
well we shouldn't be doing this no we
should be doing this so it's kind of a
schism all over the place even if you're
not in a place that is
being run like michigan is unfortunately
yeah um so i would say that
unfortunately how michigan is run no not
if you're gonna place it it's not
michigan yeah
no unfortunately yes exactly it's
probably all the states and you're there
new york and michigan are the most
unfortunate yes
very unfortunate where do you line up
there yeah so i guess it
really brings up a question of like
lineups of authority right so i mean
there are several different ways of
thinking about authority there's like
the roman catholic position which would
be like that the
the church is over the state and right
and the church
the church the state should submit to
the church's authority there's the
erastion positions that position after
thomas erastas
the state is over the church and then uh
my position would be like the sphere
sovereignty of abraham kuiper's position
that the family the church and the state
are in their separate
spheres of authority and that they're
all under government so they've got
their lanes
and that they shouldn't cross over and
also by the way that's important for
people to understand
that's uh if you look at the founding
fathers and how they intended for well
we're talking about government what the
legitimate authority is of the land
here um they believe that the family is
the central building block before
community government for municipal
government government federal government
you needed to have a central family so
that's why we do have marriage laws in
the book yeah right and i understand
i don't think that the the government
should be in the church running business
uh but i also don't think that marriage
is a fundamental human right you
it's a contract right if you find
someone who is willing to take you
don't know how i i did it yeah but
that is the same
is to self-govern it doesn't take a
village it takes a family
and then hopefully a village and then
hopefully a state and then
hopefully the federal government but the
idea that the village uh supersedes
the rights of the family no that's
that's why we have the constitution
that's why
powers were delegated so to speak to
sort of bridge that between
different theological worldviews and how
it relates to the christian worldview
that's also why a lot of founding
fathers uh people aren't going to like
this but um they
were very leery of catholics signing the
declaration of independence and not
because
but because they believed that they
might have a higher allegiance sworn to
the vatican
to rome right which was keep in mind too
is also
it's a governing body well effectively
it's not just a religious institution
and they were
really pretty apprehensive about it and
there's good reason for that fear
because that's exactly what happened in
europe and pretty much every country
right so there was much more authority
invested in the vatican what they did
at some points during history and so um
i think i think a good place for us to
start is that there are you know we're
we're not inciting
christians to go and overthrow and we're
not inciting christians to be
pacifists either right so we're getting
rid of the extremes a very good example
that came to mind
of when it would be absolutely
appropriate was in the book of daniel
uh where their prayer was basically
forbidden right so i didn't put this
verse in here i'm just gonna talk oh so
he wanted to trick us yes
pretty much uh so he just just didn't
leave something you didn't tell us
before
exactly i got to keep something out of
discovery so you guys don't have it do
you want to
deliver your point pretty much pretty
much uh i prefer latin if you know
if you don't mind um but essentially
prayer is outlawed and daniel continues
to pray right and he suffers the
consequences
of that and god delivers him from the
lions and that's kind of how the whole
story of the lions then starts
the next part is shadrach meshach and
abednego they are told that they have to
worship the king and they say
we're not going to worship you right and
no matter what
happens to us we're still not going to
do this so that's a very clear situation
where the rules of man
violate clearly the rules of god right
you're supposed to be able to pray to
god right and you're not supposed to
worship any gods before that so that's a
very clear example of when you can
right what's less clear is the question
we're on right now
can a church stay open when the
government orders them closed
in a situation like this where there's a
virus or pandemic i'm not just talking
about churches
i'm also talking about laws that violate
your your basic human rights to
sovereignty in other words
right a law that violates your right to
go make a living for example let's say
you're a fisherman
in michigan and you can't go out there
because there's a there's an outboard
motor
yes god forbid even though you're you're
several miles
from anyone yeah you can be wearing a
mask in the middle of the water i think
they may have changed that now it's hard
they're kind of going you know oh hold
on a second
ring ring red telephone sorry we were
wrong about that people can be 800 yards
from anyone else in a boat and it
doesn't matter if they have a diesel
engine okay got it okay
you don't have to be adjustable you're
forgetting human to fish transmission
yeah well documented without a mask
freaking zebra mussels
well and yeah within the state's
authority at least here in the u.s we
have several levels of authority right
right so if if i'm dealing with somebody
so let's say i'm holding a church
service i've got a police officer who
comes up and says
we can't you can't do this small group
you can't have this church service that
sort of thing
there are obviously several levels of
authority that he appeals to so that i
could appeal to
that over that and then in that sort of
situation it's really
a matter of cost benefit analysis right
so is it's is the cost of
sticking to my guns yeah yeah worth are
you willing
i think it comes down to two things it
comes down to understanding
what god's commandment is to you and
then also understanding
what is a legitimate role of government
in the united states because
for example we have 50 states right
that's this isn't the same
kind of scenario that you maybe had back
in the day if you're going back to
anywhere i mean if you're going back to
the cradle civilization
whatever day you're going back wherever
you want to go back to we have a huge
country
with 50 states and we do have a
constitution so you need to understand
what god calls you to do which is obey
the law of the land provided that it
does not
try to supersede try to usurp god's law
then you need to
understand that states all powers not
expressly outlined in the constitution
are delegated to the states now what
does that mean that means that the
states
have no but on the flip side of it this
is where sometimes libertarians don't
focus
on this enough uh on the flip side of it
that means that states do not have the
right to infringe on your rights for
example the first amendment that's not
delegated to the states
a state doesn't have the right to tell
you no you can't peaceably assemble no
you can't speak freely
they don't have the right that's the law
of the land now there can be a tyrant in
a state
who wants to say you can't actually
speak freely that's not a legitimate law
the second amendment right that they do
not have the right to infringe upon your
second amendment now i don't want to get
but i believe in constitutional carry
because you have the right to keep and
bear arms that's one to me that is so
far gone
it is unconstitutional the state does
not have the right to step in and tell
you you cannot exercise your second
amendment right
if you are honoring the law of the land
you need to know the law of the land
because
laws of the land can be subverted by
people who don't have the authority
to enforce that law so you need to
understand god's law what's expected of
you
how he expects you to submit to
authority and then the legitimate law of
the land because you're saying well god
expects me to submit to the authority
and the authority uh meaning i don't
know governor whitmer says
no church or small groups that's not the
law of the land right or the governor of
i don't know uh
let's pick any crappy state vermont says
well sorry you actually uh can no longer
uh you can no longer p
you can no longer assemble and protest
and some states are trying to do that
now by the way right because
you can't protest because it violates
social distancing they don't have the
right to you're not violating the law of
the land
if you show up and don't show up with
ar-15s and walk into a senate house
it's not a law thing it is legal but
optics not great
it doesn't get your point across you are
not violating the law of the land if you
have a governor who tries to step
in and create new laws that they don't
have the authority to create
that is very clearly outlined not only
by the constitution but the supporting
founding documents so
those two elements i think make this
when we talk about the nuance
makes those portions pretty clear right
and i think it's a good point to
delineate and i think this leads right
into
uh one of the verses that you were
actually referencing which was matthew
12. right so if you want to go through
that let me do it actually
talks a little bit about that matthew i
don't know which version was printed
here it could it's it's the new crowded
version by the way oh wow i'm going to
get a better one i'm getting it custom
made this is
all right this is just off the shelf
cross not good enough for you hey do you
notice
did you notice there's no christ oh wow
that's gone
he's kind of the key to the story wow
yeah interesting
we are so getting letters that's the
important part can you imagine if you're
still on there and he came back
stephen did you miss come on put your
hand in there put your hand in there
what i know right what are you telling
me i'm not on that thing
sorry jesus not your best impression no
it's not
jesus christ
[Laughter]
that's literally the last place i want
to be
um matthew 12. oh so this is about to if
you don't know this is about jesus doing
work on the sabbath
okay at the time he just went through
the grain fields on the sabbath his
disciples were hungry and began to pick
some heads of grain and eat them when
the pharisees saw this they said
to him look your disciples are doing
what is unlawful on the sabbath
something important here while we
provide some context pharisees
not just religious leaders right you're
talking about people who are part of the
political ruling class
when you look at pharisees and sadducees
and i know some areas yesterday
authorities some areas they didn't but
we need to understand
kind of like with martin luther and the
original diet which is a very confusing
term
this was a rebellion against a political
ruling class and that's why
the sep the first amendment the idea
that the government shouldn't be in the
church running business is so important
to avoid a situation like this
where the pharisees and sadducees were
looking to lawyer jesus into execution
by violating exactly okay so the
pharisees said look your disciples are
doing what is unlawful on the sabbath
he answered haven't you read what david
did when he and his companions were
hungry he entered the house of god
and he and his companions ate the
consecrated bread which was not
lawful for them to do but only for the
priests or haven't you read in the law
that the priests on sabbath duty in
the temple desecrate the sabbath and yet
are innocent i tell you that something
greater than the temple is here
if you had not known what these words
mean i desire mercy not sacrifice
you would not have condemned the
innocent for the son of man is lord of
the sabbath and uh
depending on which book you're actually
going into in the bible um he says that
it is
it is i believe he says it's lawful to
do good in the sabbath yeah
yeah so yeah that's the question there
are a couple of things this is why i
think this is so important um
we talk about islam versus uh
christianity forever i said go back to
the founders of the feast go back to
christ and muhammad because we can find
examples of other early christians and
not only in the bible but outside the
bible
i mean i don't know why my parents were
kind of lining me up for failure and
naming me after the first martyr
you know it happened i think it was a ph
steven though yeah
they yeah they veered a little they
wanted to cover their tracks
so um i know we can find a lot of
examples of christians who were
in trouble violating the law but they
may be wrong
very possible so let's go to christ
christ clearly violated
the law here in several ways right now
is christ wrong did he sin
well if if jesus christ sinned so in
other words of violating the law is
sinful you have to throw the whole thing
out yeah
you can't use it you can't use it so
obviously
no this was not sinful because jesus did
not sin and again people if you're
watching this and you're not a christian
you're going to love jesus
i don't care this isn't for you so well
it's not circular logic either no
it's not circular logic so here's what's
important here uh two different dynamics
that i think are interesting to sort of
uh
take a look at um i shouldn't have said
take a look at now i sound like you
which we can which we can observe
the dynamic of man's law versus god's
law
okay so we have the law of the land
which is don't do any work on the
sabbath that's the law of the land and
you have a pharisee like we talked about
part of the religious and political
ruling class saying
uh are you breaking the law because
you're looking for reason to put him to
death
absolutely so then you have man's law
versus god's law he's saying no actually
it is lawful to do good in the sabbath
but here's something else that's
interesting to me
is um this also gives us an example of
god's law and the letter of god's law
versus the
spirit and purpose of god's law because
you know what other law
christ violated here god's law yeah
about the sabbath in other words you
could say
he violated the law by working on the
sabbath
so is it a sin for somebody to do some
to serve others
on the sabbath and this is even in
bigger conversation where are we still
beholden to the law are we free from it
because christ said he came to fulfill
the law
we want to talk about going several
layers deep right um but in this
instance no of course
that means that it is not a vi it's not
sinful
to violate god's law as it was
interpreted at that point
why um because he wanted to or he was
actually he violated the letter of god's
law which just don't know what you're
going to do
but don't shave your neck with electric
and this can be a straight blade what
are you talking about
that wasn't god's intent for the law the
intent and the purpose the spirit of
the law was a gift to us in the sabbath
and so it was very clear and said
it is good to do good on the sabbath so
he violated the letter of god's law how
it was outlined by religious leaders and
institutions of the day to fulfill the
spirit of god's law which was
loving his neighbor and we can go to the
good samaritan story there but who was
my neighbor and he was brilliant using
that he was the he was the first
socrates if you look at it back
you look at how he used this the
socratic method and turn it back on
people the reason he did that a lot
again context is not that he wasn't
answering the question
he was trying to avoid being crucified
immediately before fulfilling his
purpose because they were always trying
to catch him
well yeah he was definitely breaking
their interpretation of the law for sure
and also
the last verse you read there for the
son of man is lord of the sabbath
right it is an authority question so
that that's so it's
you're basically he's saying you're
talking to the guy who gave you the
sabbath so there's something more
important here
i actually i actually can tell you what
it means and what it doesn't mean
right don't tell me right and that's
what i meant right so and that that goes
back to your point about the second
amendment so what jesus did is exactly
like
a government coming in and saying that
you cannot possess a firearm the second
amendment doesn't exist can we pause it
i just want to finish my one point we
want to go to that so
here's one thing because there are
different like we talked about the
different lines nuances i know you speak
aramaic and latin and greek
yeah and um want to be clear we are not
saying throw caution in the wind and
just go forward and violate all no
that's not what anybody here is saying
and i do think that there is uh a
healthy debate
or there should be a healthy debate
among christians as to where that line
is where disobedience uh
to or rebellion against a law is sinful
okay
but what is completely irrefutable is to
assume that
any disobedience of the law is sinful
that is incorrect
because jesus disobeyed the law several
times so the christians who line up and
anytime you
anytime you break the law that's a sin
right that is verifiably false
entirely false according to what the
bible tells us because jesus was sinless
and he did it not only here
hey if you enjoyed this video subscribe
or hit the notification bell and hit
all notifications because uh not all
notifications work now if you just hit
the normal notification bell i think
there's some videos playing in boxes but
of course do consider uh subscribing at
lighterofcredit.com
because there's a bunch of content that
could never make it onto youtube and i
think the
the box is playing there's a video
playing in a box with